[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
débat du second tour des élections
législatives pour la 10e circonscription
des yvelines un débat retransmis sur
téléphiles 78 et radio sensations
dimanche prochain près de quatre vingt
neuf mille électeurs sont appelés à
voter pour choisir leurs députés et ils
auront le choix cette fois ci entre
aurore bergé candidat de la république
en marche et jean frédéric poisson
député sortant candidat es divers-droite
investi par les républicains le parti
chrétien-démocrate bonsoir à tous les
deux voilà je rappelle que lors du
premier tour
aurore bergé vous êtes arrivé en tête
avec un peu plus de 46% des voix
exprimées contre 19% pour vous jean
frédéric poisson l'abstention était de
presque 40 4% pour ce premier tour
quelques précisions sur ce débat
évidemment votre temps de parole seront
chronométrés et nous parlerons notamment
d'agriculture et de fiscalité
première question d'introduction quel
député serez vous si vous êtes élue
dimanche ce sera la même question pour
tous les deux ont commencé avec vous
auront berger vous avez la parole en
première bonsoir et merci de cette
invitation j'ai toujours été favorable
au débat dont je suis ravi qu'on puisse
la voir sur votre chaîne et puis sur
l'antenne
également on avait déjà eu cette
question avant le premier tour alors
j'ai pas varié entre le premier et le
second tour par rapport est ce que je
souhaitais dire peut-être ajouter une
précision par rapport à la manière avec
laquelle on a fait campagne et la
manière avec laquelle je souhaite être
demain parlementaire on a fait une
campagne de terrain j'ai pris l'habitude
de dire en réunion publique que j'étais
pas une notable pas plus que mon
suppléant et qu'on n'avait pas
l'intention de le devenir
ça veut dire tout simplement qu'on veut
plus se contenter d'avoir des
parlementaires qui ressort de faire du
porte à porte ou les cinq ans il faut
que cette manière de faire le fait
d'aller à la rencontre continue raison
pour laquelle j'ai par exemple annoncé
qu'on aurait une permanence
parlementaire physique mais également
des permanences qui tournerait dans les
différentes municipalités
j'en ai déjà parlé à un certain nombre
de maires qui sont prêts à nous
accueillir au sein de leur mairie parce
qu'encore une fois c'est pas aux
habitants ce n'est pas aux élus d'aller
vers le parlementaire c'est aux
parlementaires d'aller vers les élus
quoi j'ai beaucoup ressenti dans cette
campagne en besoin d'eux
dialogue de démocratie locale de faire
parler d ensemble des organisations qui
se parle plus vraiment et c'est aussi ça
le rôle d'un parlementaire d'être ce
facilitateur
enfin et même si vous entendez ces je me
suis prêt à ouvrir dans la campagne
mais contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
poisson je n'ai pas du tout l'intention
d'être une députée muette j'ai jamais
considérer qu'un parti c'était une
caserne un clan un con au contraire j'ai
toujours été extrêmement libre et j'ai
l'intention de le rester loyal au
président de la république qui a été élu
qui nous permettra évidemment aussi de
l'aide parce que il donne une dynamique
très forte à ces législatives mais je
garderai ma liberté comme j'ai toujours
et même question geoffrey tels que
autres sont alors la situation un peu
différente pour vous puisque vous êtes
député sortant mais à quel député serez
vous si vous êtes élu a dit mme en jeu
celui que je crois j'ai été jusqu'ici
c'est à dire d'abord travailleurs est
investi dans l'exercice de mon mandat
parlementaire
deuxièmement un député libre et
contrairement à madame berger moi je ne
signerai jamais de documents ou de
charte promettant l' avance de signé
tous les textes de loi présenté par le
gouvernement je considère que c'est
contraire à l'exercice même il ya
l'esprit même de la fonction d'un
parlementaire
troisièmement je comprends bien tout ce
que madame berger est en train de
découvrir de l'animation de la
circonscription
j'ai été un des plus un député
présent auprès des habitants auprès des
communes je n'ai jamais manqué à
personne
ceux qui ont sollicité mon élément
toujours eu quelle que soit leur couleur
politique leur type de préoccupations ou
leurs choix personnels et j'ai tout à
fait l'intention de continuer dans ce
sens
merci pour vos réponses et ce premier
tour de table on va passer à la première
thématique de ce débat l'agriculture
puisque la circonscription est la plus
rurale du département l'a vu encore
cette semaine avec les producteurs de
lait le monde agricole semble vivre dans
une crise perpétuelle alors quelles sont
vos propositions pour l'agriculture
celle que vous pourriez éventuellement
porter à l'assemblée nationale jean
frédéric poisson vous proposait
notamment selon votre profession de foi
je cite que les agriculteurs puissent
vivre de leur métier et que les
réglementations qui encadrent leurs
activités soient ramenés au niveau des
dispositions européennes pour vous il ya
trop de trop de règles trop de
d'encadrement c'est le sentiment général
de l'agriculture comme d'ailleurs de
beaucoup d'autres activités celles des
élus locaux également sur le poids des
réglementations qui empêchent en réalité
de faire beaucoup de choses sans
véritable raison
il y à cette volonté des agriculteurs au
civil dignement de leur activité est
peut être un peu moins de leurs
subventions et un peu plus de leur
savoir faire et de leur engagement
personnel et il y a en tout cas des
choses à modifier profondément dans les
doigts porté par la majorité sortante et
en particulier cette folie qui consiste
à considérer agriculteurs d'abord comme
des aménageurs du territoire et pas
comme des entrepreneurs
je crois qu'il y a une volonté avoir une
réel fermeté à l'égard de l'évolution de
cette loi dite de modernisation de
l'agriculture qui a été adopté il ya
deux ans et puis un équilibre aussi à
trouver par rapport aux exigences de la
biodiversité de la transition écologique
ou faire très attention à tous ses
aspects les agriculteurs sont depuis
longtemps engagée dans une volonté de
réduire l'utilisation de produits à
caractère agrochimique on va dire ça
comme ça il faut d accompagner continuer
ce mouvement mais l'équilibré trouverez
subtil temps qu'il ya ces trois aspects
de réglementation de santé pérennité des
exploitations sur le plan économique et
puis d'accompagnement pour tout un tas
de d'activité puis il ya le schéma sur
la ruralité avec l'agencé nationale de
développement de la ruralité dont j'ai
déjà parlé ici même il ya maintenant une
quinzaine de jours aurore bergé si l'on
se réfère au programme présidentiel
d'emmanuel macron l'objectif numéro un
pour l'agriculture c'est à garantir des
prix justes pour que les agriculteurs
puissent vivre de leur travail
comment vous souhaitez agir dans ce sens
à ce que vous pouvez développer un peu
ce cette idée là oui déjà on est encore
un département agricole on est le
deuxième département agricole
franciliens et malheureusement on a
perdu depuis 1970 dans notre département
on a divisé par trois le nombre
d'exploitations agricoles
il reste un peu moins de 1000 dans notre
département donc c'est un enjeu
essentiel évidemment de continuer à
assurer la pérennité de nos
exploitations agricoles on assure
comment la pérennité nos exploitations
agricoles avec ce que vous dites
en effet qui est au coeur du programme
présidentiel d'assurer un prix juste
c'est la raison pour laquelle on dit
plusieurs choses dans le projet
le premier c'est de maintenir le budget
de la pac qui est extrêmement important
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président lui-même s'est engagé sur ce
point accompagner les agriculteurs dans
la modernisation de leur outil de
travail dans le plan d'investissement
qu'on propose c'est un prendre 5 50
milliards d'euros sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat 5 milliards d'euros 10
milliards d'euros sont consacrés à
l'agriculture c'est l'aide à
l'installation des jeunes allument il ya
comme ces 5 au 10 milliards 5 milliards
$ seront consacrés à l'agriculture c'est
à dire 10 % de ce qui est prévu dans le
plan d'investissement sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat ce qui est quand même un
engagement sans précédent sur la
question agricole l'aide à
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
par exemple avec l'obtention d'un prêt
de 50 euros pour les aider à s'installer
et puis c'est aussi toute la question la
réglementation en effet on le présente
public a coutume de dire que finalement
on est parfois un peu trop bon élève sur
la transposition des directives
européennes dans les tendances à sûr
transposer c'est pas forcément un
objectif qui va falloir poursuivre
notamment par la question du droit à
l'erreur l'administration doit
accompagner doit aider et ne doit pas
juste venir sanctionner a posteriori
notamment deux agriculteurs jean
frédéric poisson si on se réfère une
nouvelle fois aussi à votre à votre
profession de foi vous voulez développer
les circuits courts ça passe aussi par
ça le développement de l'agriculture
comment on peut on peut aider les
agriculteurs à inonder on va dire le
marché local innover je ne sais pas
parce que vous savez inonder le marché
local
c'est peut-être une mauvaise exécution
de donner le nom s'est passé pas eu
qu'une critique d'autres formulations
c'est celle à l'agriculture locale ne
peut pas produire tous les types de
produits agricoles dont la consommation
de la besoin parce que les sols ne
conviennent pas parce qu'il ya pas tous
les types d'élevage et de d'animaux
familiers des tas de raisons pour
lesquelles c'est difficile en tout cas
il faut favoriser tout cela nous avons à
la communauté d'agglomération mis en
place cet atelier de découpe qui permet
aux producteurs et aux éleveurs locaux
d'avoir des facilités pour découper
leurs animaux et demain les vendre dans
le cadre de circuits courts ce genre de
démarche et là me paraît devoir être
devoir être développée sous quelle forme
c'est à voir avec les acteurs eux-mêmes
mais il ya déjà beaucoup de choses qui
sont faites dans ce sens c'est dans
cette direction il ya des marchés locaux
avec beaucoup de producteurs qui
viennent vendre leurs produits des
ventes de produits à la ferme dans
énormément d'établissements et de faire
de notre région
donc c'est une mécanique je crois qu'il
faut renforcer
puis je voudrais marquer simplement une
forme d'hésitation pour ne pas dire
d'étonnement dans tous les journaux ce
matin on apprend que dans les lettres de
cadrage budgétaire le gouvernement
cherche déjà 32 milliards pour l'année
prochaine donc j'invite les agriculteurs
a accueilli avec beaucoup de prudence
les engagements d'aidé d'investissement
qui sont aujourd'hui portées par les
candidats dans marche
je voudrais vous faire réagir maintenant
on verra au temps de parole après
s'afficher sur un sujet qui concerne les
yvelines notamment le sud yvelines et
qui inquiète beaucoup d'élus locaux
c'est la fusion envisagée entre les deux
départements
vous êtes opposés jean frédéric poisson
à ce projet qu'en est-il pour vous aux
rares berger est-ce que vous soutenez
cette idée de projet porté par les deux
présidents des assemblées
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire plusieurs
fois dans la campagne je considère que
le sud du département ne doit pas juste
une grande réserve de foncier on a un
problème dans ce département qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression que
tout vent tout cas l'essentiel est
fléché vers le nord du département et la
vallée de la seine au détriment du sud
du département
la fusion entre les hauts-de-seine et
les yvelines est un vrai risque nous
fait courir de renforcer encore cette
inégalité qui en train de s'instaurer
entre le nord et le sud du département
alors moi je souhaite déjà qu'une
concertation qui existent on peut pas
avoir un projet de cette ampleur qui est
juste négocié entre les présidents des
deux assemblées sam peut plus
fonctionner comme ça les élus locaux
n'ont pas été associés n'ont pas été
consultés les habitants n'ont pas été
consultés
j'en ai parlé notamment yves vandewalle
qu'ils président du parc naturel
régional de la vallée heureuse qui est
conseiller départemental qui s'opposent
à cette fusion on va se revoir très
prochainement pour continuer à en
discuter également je l'espère avec
jean-noël barrot qui j'espère sera élu
sur la 2e circonscription parce que on a
des problématiques à ses proches j'en
fais avec passion pour que vous êtes
pour ou contre
à titre personnel à titre personnel je
souhaite déjà qui nous concerne est ce
que vous êtes pour ou contre s est
greffé un avis oui j'avais monsieur
poisson
si vous voulez je peux pas juste dire on
est pour ou on est contre
sans avoir moi même discuté avec les
présidents ces départements et vous
savez pertinemment de toute façon que le
premier ministre ait présenté un joli
corps ont un mot à dire sur la question
de la fusion de ces deux départements
aujourd'hui président de la république
est plutôt très réservé sur
l'opportunité de cette fusion donc moi
je pense que toute façon ça ne pourra
pas avoir lieu en l'état actuel des
choses et ça ne peut pas être continuer
à être sage jusqu'au bout quand vous
ricanez ne peut pas être avec surtout de
l'absence totale l'absence totale de
concertation qui ait lieu j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire d'ailleurs
face à vous en débarquant jardin tu
prends 12h30 la semaine dernière nous
vous connaissez très bien ma position
sur le sujet pour conclure jean frédéric
poisson sur cette question de la
toujours vous est farouchement opposé je
suis opposé à cette fusion j'ai fait
prendre par les vous pourrez d'ailleurs
su arrêter processus en tant que député
selon vous arrêtez processus c'est en
tout cas continuer à dire que l'on y est
opposé les raisons pour lesquelles j
suis je suis depuis l'origine j'avais
fait prendre une motion par la
communauté d'agglomération de
rambouillet territoire contre ce projet
de fusion et j'aimerais que les grandes
initiatives est au moins une position
claire sur cette question aussi
importante le pré ministre et le
président de la république en plus qu'un
mot à dire d'ailleurs c'est pas le
président de la république mais en
l'espèce un décret gouvernemental qui
arrêtera ou pas la fusion de ces deux
départements
j'ai cru comprendre moi au contraire de
ce que vous dites madame que le ministre
de l'intérieur était très favorable à
faire de la métropole de paris une
métropole sur le modèle de celle de lyon
or dans la métropole de lyon il n'y a
plus de départements c'est-à-dire là où
est la métropole le département là où
est la métropole de départements
d'exercice plus de compétences si
effectivement c'est le schéma qui doit
prévoit qu'ils doivent prévaloir pour
l'île de france
ça promet une fusion totale une
disparition totale des hauts-de-seine
dans le périmètre de la métropole de
paris est donc dans ce cadre la fusion
avec tes yvelines devient encore plus
aléatoire est encore plus problématique
pour nos territoires
je termine en disant qu' il n'est pas
vrai madame de dire que comment dire
l'ensemble des moyens sont concentrés
sur le nord du département car si on
regarde
aux sommes qui sont versées par habitant
dans le département dans le sud du
département des yvelines
en réalité par rapport à la richesse
produite le département du sud des
yvelines profite au contraire d'une
partie une même d'une partie conséquente
de la richesse qui est produite par les
entreprises qui elles malheureusement
pour nous son bord vers gers étiez
peut-être réagira plus loin qu'on verra
votre temps de parole et on va vite
passer à une deuxième thématique parce
que le temps passe rapidement ajuster
rapidement
avez vous fait des c de la politique du
département ce n'est pas toujours le cas
moi je constate en tout cas qu il y
apprit que je constate qu'il ya six mois
je pense que le seul enjeu de l'égalité
territoriale est majeur et qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une distorsion entre le nord
et le sud de notre département
par contre par rapport à ce qui a été
dit enfin monsieur poisson sur le projet
du ministre de l'intérieur s'est
absolument pas le cas ce qui a été dit
pendant la campagne est réaffirmée par
le ministre intérieur c'est que tu as
raison dans le cas de la métropole
aix marseille mais c'est un sujet robert
tanguay jeu paquet de confusion non plus
qu'on fasse croire que tout d'un coup
par magie le ministre de l'intérieur est
supprimé si on fait supprimer les
départements au sein de l'ile-de-france
ce qui a été dit pendant la campagne
réaffirmée par le ministre c'est de dire
que quand il ya un écart par exemple
entre le département des bouches du
rhône et la métropole aix marseille à
deux communes qui ne sont pas dans le
même périmètre
donc là on peut s'interroger sur la
légitimité d'avoir est une métropole et
en départements parce qu'on a continué
achevée très des compétences enchevêtrés
des moyens et c'est beaucoup plus
dispendieux et pas forcément efficace ça
n'est absolument pas le même sujet au
sein de l'ile-de-france
on va voir vos temps de parole
s'afficher dans quelques secondes et on
va enchaîner sur la deuxième thématique
la fiscalité qui est aussi au coeur de
l'actualité on le sait voilà vous êtes
vous avez un petit peu d'avancé sur
berges et on va rééquilibrer sa avec la
suite de l'émission la fiscalité donc un
sujet sensible évidemment pour les
gouvernements qui se succèdent aussi
pour les français ou le cerro en verger
la république en marche soit une baisse
des cotisations sociales pour les
salariés
une baisse qui serait en revanche
financée par une hausse de la csg de 1,7
point on a vu un peu dans le débat
actuel que ça pouvait inquiéter beaucoup
de personnes que les politiques vos
opposants politiques vous le mettez en
avant aussi l'objectif votre objectif
c'est de quoi de valoriser le travail
avant tout de faire une prime au travail
il ya deux objectifs c'est déjà en effet
de rendre du pouvoir d'achat
immédiatement vous
larié puisque clairement sur leur fiche
de paye on supprimerait la part
vieillesse et la part maladie de leurs
cotisations
donc c'est un gain immédiat de pouvoir
d'achat pour l'ensemble des salariés
et puis c'est aussi faire en sorte que
pour les chefs d'entreprise qu'il soit
plus facile de recruter parce que le
train coûtera moins cher pour eux
conseille évidemment les deux sujets qui
sont importants d'ailleurs sur la
fiscalité des entreprises on en a
malheureusement assez peu parlé et tout
notre jeu c'est quand même qu'à une
attractivité plus importante au sein de
notre pays pour justement arrivé en fin
de quinquennat c'est en tout cas
l'objectif que nous nous sommes à 7 % de
taux de chômage ce qui est loin d'être
le cas malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est
notamment la baisse de la fiscalité sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés pour leur à 25%
pour le ramener à la vanille à 11,0 la
moyenne européenne qui est à 25% et qui
crée encore une fois une distorsion une
inégalité entre notre pays et les autres
pays et partenaires européens donc c'est
tout un enjeu d'attractivité et de
restitution de pouvoir d'achat aux
français qui nous anime jean frédéric
poisson vous êtes vous vous favorable
pour une diminution radicale de la
pression fiscale sans augmentation de la
csg mais du coup comment comment on
finance cette diminution de la de la
pression fiscale
bref ne pas parler de réforme de l'état
je n'ai pas changé d'avis depuis la
campagne primaire à droite et du centre
je pense que ceux qui n'ambitionne pas
de réformer avant toute chose et de
baisser le train de vie de l'état de
manière conséquente ne parviendront pas
à financer toutes les promesses qu'ils
ont faites je répète ce matin même nous
découvrons que les promesses de emmanuel
bach contre son gouvernement pour budget
de la france leur les conduisent à
devoir trouver 32 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires dont pour l'instant on
n'a pas un fifrelin donc je ne sais pas
comment on financera tout ça par
ailleurs sur la question de la pression
fiscale rendre du pouvoir d'achat aux
salariés
parfait ça va se faire au détriment du
pouvoir d'achat des fonctionnaires des
retraités des demandeurs d'emploi des
personnes qui sont en arrêt maladie
celle de tous ceux qui payent de la csg
tous toutes les personnes payent
d'assiéger et même les mêmes les
salariés au fond qui ont un peu
d'épargné qui ont mis un peu d'argent de
côté compte acheter un petit bien de
rapports pour un loyer etc tout cela
effectivement ira vers le virage vert
une augmentation de la pression qui
s'exercera sur tous les français
indistinctement 20 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires c'est un choc à peu près
sans précédent en tout cas dans
l'histoire de notre pays de l'histoire
récente et les français doivent beaucoup
s'inquiéter de cette affaire parce que
par ailleurs on voit bien que les
mesures qu'ils seraient censés compenser
cet éventuel cette fête cette hausse de
la csg qui sera éventuellement d'un
virus 7 % peut-être même pourquoi pas un
peu plus en réalité ne sera que
tardivement récompensé rexel
d'habitation qui domine à sion exonérés
pour 80% et de l'esprit qui se fera par
tiers qui se fera par tiers sa 7ème si
c'est des piscines sur trois ans pour
l'exercice 2010 2019 2020 dans tout le
monde à payer la csg plein pot dans
cette exonération par exemple la taxe
d'habitation est ce que vous c'est un
projet que vous voyez en exonération de
la taxe d'habitation c'est pas le
contraire c'est à dire que la wii ce jeu
de 1,6 point de la csg interviendra au
même moment que les générations pour 80%
des français non de la taxe d'habitation
vais essayer de faire peur en disant une
traction vous n'aurez que des os et je
ne serai pas des baisses je ne fais pas
moi je dis juste que pour certains comme
les français qui vont être un petit peu
perdant dans cette affaire je suis web
les huitièmes tout sera neutralisée nous
avons un projet qui est sérieux et qui
budgétés moi je vois qu entre la
présidentielle et les législatives les
républicains ont changé complètement
leurs projets le pendant la présidence
au coeur moi je l'investis par les
républicains mais quand ça vous arrange
vous attendez des noms auraient pu
jusqu'à présent les républicains qui
préparent les belles demeures de votre
10% de baisse sur l'impôt sur le revenu
sans changer le mode de financement du
projet global qui est présenté par le
parti dont vous êtes investis oui
j'aimerais bien savoir comment ses
finances et ça n'est pas financée dans
le projet je voulais produire ce qu'il y
aura une faible hausse de la csg 9,7
points en effet qui interviendra au même
moment une exonération pour 80% des
français dont la taxe d'habitation 6
même engagement de la maison des
associations mais c'est un engagement du
président de la république alors et il
m'apparaît assez clair depuis le début
de son mandat que le président de la
république tient ses promesses dont elle
tient ses engagements sur monsieur vous
avez le droit de le contester
publiquement vous avez le droit d'être
en désaccord politique mais arrêtez de
mentir en disant que ce que je dis est
faux que le président de la république
d'après dit cela de la république a
clairement dit si en janvier deux hommes
très très bonne avancée 13 enfants sur
le temps passe on ne me traitez pas de
manteau rouge et or est vrai un petit
peu le devoir envoyer moi même à vos
propres contradictions
nulle part il est écrit que la hausse de
la csg n'interviendra que pour un tiers
en même temps que le phasage la taxe
d'habitation ça ça n'est pas vraiment y
arriver car résidence et ça n'est pas
vrai la hausse de l'assiette la hausse
de la csg doit intervenir plus comment
vous à l'étrier vous allez augmenter le
vous n'allez augmenter la csg et baisser
des taux de cotisation sociale que pour
les gens qui sont exonérés de taxe
d'habitation ça n'a aucun sens je vous
dis que là je savais bien exonéré
excusez-moi savez bien
vous le savez bien c'est par tiers la
taxe d'habitation c'est sur trois ans et
la siagi c'est plein pot tout de suite
c'est ça le coeur de votre projet ne me
dis pas le contraire
ou alors ça veut dire qu'on change
d'avis tous les jours par ailleurs la
tenue des promesses du président de la
république pardonnez-moi sur tout ce qui
concerne le comportement d'un certain
nombre de ministres et leurs ennuis
judiciaires et leurs problèmes avec la
moralité
excusez moi de vous dire que là on est
très loin des engagements est très loin
des promesses de renouvellement de
moralisation et c'est maintenant on nous
a rebattu les oreilles pendant donc la
bande à un autre sujet vous souhaitez
peut-être agir à ce qui vient d'être dit
ou alors on enchaîne peut-être pour
votre pour votre première carte blanche
on va on va voir vos temps de parole
elle s'affiche et dans peu de temps
voilà dans quelques secondes ils vont
s'afficher et puis on va rester à votre
carte blanche je vous pourrez mettre en
avant le point que vous souhaitez chacun
pour rééquilibrer un petit peu elle est
temps de parole d'ici quelques jours
en tout cas voilà on les voit donc
aurore bergé un petit peu un petit peu
d'avancé 30 secondes d'avancé à 25
précisément on va passer cette carte
blanche qui vous permet à chacun de
mettre en avant le point que vous
souhaitez on devait aborder initialement
à une troisième thématique la politique
familiale que vous voulez ça nous porte
et on n'aura pas le temps de le faire
j'invite une nouvelle fois les
téléspectateurs à se rendre sur vos
sites internet respectifs pour aller
plus loin peut-être jean frédéric
poisson vous débutez vous avez un peu
plus de temps pour votre pour votre
carte blanche allez-y vous avez une
minute trois mois je voudrais simplement
soumettre à la réflexion de nos
auditeurs et des téléspectateurs cette
citation que je tire d'un discours du
président de la république il a prononcé
le 28 février dernier à angers et je
vous en donne lecture est ce que
quelqu'un peut penser raisonnablement
que élu président il aura une majorité
présidentielle uniquement avec son parti
moi je n'y crois pas dit emmanuel macron
non seulement ça n'est pas possible mais
ça n'est pas souhaitable parce que ce
serait un hold up
voilà ce que disait emmanuel mal conduit
même au mois de février la semaine
dernière le mois dernier par dont il ya
trois mois
enfin dans la campagne présidentielle
nous sommes en phase alors je ne sais
pas s'il faut retenir les termes de hold
up ce sont les termes du président je
lui laisse le soin de cette appréciation
j'aimerais bien d'ailleurs que madame
berger réagi sur ce propos du président
de la république pour savoir s'il est
toujours d'accord avec lui en attendant
moi je dis simplement que les majorités
pléthorique font là un affaiblissement
provoque un affaiblissement sans
précédent du pays la dernière fois
d'ailleurs madame bergé s'en souviendra
sans doute puisque c'est son mentor
alain juppé qui était aux affaires
470 députés de l'udf et du rpr en 95 des
grèves en 97 une dissolution et rien
n'est arrangé au milieu faites attention
les français se rendent compte
d'ailleurs et en ce moment il faut bien
faire attention à ne pas confier à un
pouvoir exécutif déjà très renforcée qui
musèle de la liberté de la presse ou en
tout cas qu'il latin qui met en coupe
réglée ces parlementaires le maine et
emmanuel macron dit lui même qu'il
faudra cornaquait de près les députés
parce que sinon ça pourrait être le
foutoir il fait signe à un engagement
rarement dire de voter tous les textes à
ses futurs députés ou député putatif
je dis simplement ne mettez pas en
danger les libertés du parlement et
donné une opposition à monsieur matheron
on va du coup laissé répondre peut-être
hors marché si vous souhaitez répondre
en tout cas c'est votre carte blanche à
vous avez dit je remercie moi je préfère
utiliser ma carte blanche pour dire des
choses positives plutôt qu'être juste
dans la contradiction des choses
négatives on ne sait pas on état
d'esprit c'est pas celui qui a guidé ma
campagne
en effet j'ai reçu ce soutien d'alain
juppé c'est un soutien dont je suis fier
et qui m'honore je suis la seule
candidate salir et qu'il n'appartient
pas justement républicain qui était
soutenu par lui et encore une fois je le
remercie je remercie les électeurs qui
au premier tour ont fait le choix mais
seulement de soutenir ma candidature en
3000 personnes qui ont fait le choix de
voter pour moi et gilles schmitt mon
suppléant qui est adjoint au maire à
rambouillet et je les invite évidemment
à maintenir ce choix au second tour et à
continuer à voter pour nous on a une
opportunité formidable aujourd'hui dans
notre pays
recomposé complètement la vie politique
de ce pays en cessant justement le
tic-tac permanent entre la gauche et la
droite qui n'a pas permis de réformer
notre pays qui n'a pas permis de rendre
plus égalitaire et de le rendre plus
juste
je crois au projet du président de la
république c'est d'ailleurs le projet
qui a été choisi dans notre
circonscription en le plaçant en tête du
premier tour et massivement au second
tour loin des ambiguïtés de certains qui
mettait sur le même plan l'extrême
droite et elle m'a donc je les invite à
confirmer ce choix à donner une majorité
au présent de la république et à faire
le choix justement de l'optimisme en
votant pour nous dimanche prochain
c'est la fin de ce débat pour le second
tour des élections législatives pour la
10e circonscription des yvelines on voit
les temps sa fiche et voilà vous êtes à
presque à égalité bravo à vous deux
merci d'être venus en plateau merci à
vous aussi de nous avoir suivi pensez
évidemment aller voter et dimanche
en attendant vous retrouvez est cette
émission en replay sur tv fil 78 points
comme ou l'application tv fil 78 ce
radio sensations aussi bonne soirée à
tous bonne soirée à toutes
[Musique]